fact i mean they might be people
president number 44 wants to help the
left center more former president obama
if that's his real name
is launching a campaign to stop the
spread of disinformation which he called
a real challenge for our democracy and
also for his former veep who's
challenged by questions like what's my
name and why am i nude in the rose
garden
tweeted obama part of the reason it's
hard to bring about change is because we
live in a media environment that
elevates falsehoods as much as truths
and divides people as much as much as it
brings them together
through the obama foundation we're
working to empower and equip emerging
leaders to tackle issues like the spread
of disinformation
of course as plenty of people
immediately pointed out it was obama's
democratic allies who cooked up the
russian collusion hoax or how about nick
sandman hands up don't shoot don't say
gay or the hunter laptop story they're
all stories where the public was
shielded from the truth with help from
the democratic friendly legacy media who
try to diss any information that
threatens their narrative and by
narrative i mean load of cow dung
and let's not forget this is the guy who
once awarded was awarded lie of the year
for saying if you like your health care
plan you can keep it he spoke about
disinformation for almost an hour today
which we now play in its entirety
thank you so much
hello stanford
my name's not stanford
oh i'd rather watch that shirtless
trampoline video kilmead sells on his
website
so is obama a credible judge of
disinformation let's listen to a clip of
his audio book for reference
it's getting way too complicated for me
there are white folks and then they're
ignorant like you
now you know that guy
sorry has my got nothing on me right
wait my [ __ ]
buy your own damn fries
that's my favorite obama of all the
obamas that's my favorite
trey
my theory is that you if
nobody from any political side is a
credible source of missive because we
all have our cognitive biases it could
be trump or it could be obama it's the
same problem you're going to have to
find an independent voice is this glass
half full half empty you go with cliches
like that everything that you pointed
out i mean even just the affordable
health care act which was not about even
being affordable or health care this is
what democrats do i look there's no
doubt that republicans attempt to play
this card as well
and the fact is
don't trust politicians you've got to go
out seek your own information and decide
but what the left does today in all of
the things that we've seen just this
week is like doxing is bad unless it
accomplishes my goals free speech is
dangerous unless it accomplishes
my goals and it goes on and on and on
and having worked for many years as a
journalist
it's really scary as hell because this
is just another arena that they want to
assert complete control
over something that is so sacred and
that's free speech yeah you know it is
it's it's effect when they talk about
disinformation they act like it only
goes one way so they're not interested
in the disinformation they pump out cat
when you think about an independent like
like let's say there was a
disinformation initiative
who do you think would be the person
that you would trust in that world
no single person could do it right um
how about a panel
maybe i guess i mean people trust obama
or they like obama a lot because he's
our hottest president
what he's obviously the hottest
president he's obviously far and away
the hottest president you just insulted
the ancestors of mr polk i don't doubt
that he was a dreamboat nope not like
obama polk was a dreamboat not like
obama jfk obama obamacare
mama is way hotter unless he has a hairy
devil
but we should not
again look you open this can of worms
now cat poke i it opens in my mind every
time i look at the guy
super hot but you have a lesson we all
have to learn is just because someone's
super hot that doesn't mean you should
trust them
so
that's the lesson so no because one
single person or a panel people you know
he's talking about you're deciding which
voice is elevating this above this or
that the best way to do it does not have
is to not have people deciding which
voices should get elevated and which
should not get elevated possible i know
that twitter's full of crap of course
it's full of crap but i think it's
better than having people you know
considering that i can't say whatever
crap that i want to say having that be
in jeopardy
whether you're hot is obama or not
you know uh morgan uh that was
incredibly sexist she said and i
apologize uh we're gonna have a talk
with her afterwards it's just
unacceptable
uh anyway where was i
what do you think do you think he's a
credible source
a credible judge no he's a politician
you know and and they have a bias which
is not bad right he's trying to convince
people of his viewpoint and his way of
the world but it it's sort of i don't
know i guess it's it's ridiculous to
think in many ways that there are any
independent voices anymore maybe you
know there's a everybody i think brings
our own biases to the table even
journalists you know no matter what
network you're on um you have your own
thoughts you have your own way of
thinking of things and it's just i don't
know that it's really credible to say
that one person can be totally
independent and totally unbiased so
that's why you should have a market
place of ideas and be able to talk about
things and debate things and
and have multiple channels and not block
people on twitter not have the president
on twitter right i mean everybody uh
should be able to make their own
decisions i think i'm against people
making their own decisions tyrus you
know that yeah i just ignore it um
besides the the physical stuff cat had a
great point as far as
one person can't do it yeah right and
and honestly uh
obama if he was really taking this
seriously
the way you do this is you reach out to
george bush you reach out to president
trump you reach out to
clinton and the presidents come together
yeah like super friends and but to in
the meet where everyone is represented
to promote
the idea of someone
lack of disinformation from both sides
that's how you solve a problem like that
you take two prominent figures from both
sides of the aisle and then they're the
refs yeah because then one there will be
checks and balances without checks and
balances you're never going to get it's
just hey i just want to take great
upcoming guys with democratic ideas and
make sure they have a voice of course
that's what he's going to do but if
there's a young up-and-coming republican
who says things against them then the
first argument is well this guy's
different information not he has a
different set of ideals and ideas that
we need to talk about but he's not
trying to fix problems right like he
said that's what i'm saying that's the
only way
russia russia russia right because
everything was about russia you know
fixed the election in 16. everything
about trump is russia uh russia and this
is the next version of that now
everything that the republicans do is
disinformation i have to go now morgan
but i was making avengers couldn't even
agree on things that's true iron man
they broke up like six times yes that is
so true human beings they're just you
know they're they're it's hard for them
to get along
that made no sense hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else